deuxième édition on a déjà eu une
première édition donc l'année dernière
avec 24 clubs donc l'idée c'est de
réunir les amoureux du football autour
d'un événement festif
c'est vrai que nous puisqu'ils l'intérêt
de ce club afin de se trouver la parade
on sait qui est des clubs professionnels
pour cette édition il y aura huit clubs
professionnels donc pas des moindres si
je puis dire puisqu'il y aura donc
l'olympique lyonnais l'olympique de
marseille bruges il ya aussi c'est un
deuxième club de belges qui ont mon
centrale est finalisé donc donc ça on
sera un symbole peu l'as nancy lorraine
le red star donc ça c'est là le plateau
qui aura pour cette nouvelle édition
essaie de garder une recette qui
fonctionne il ya toujours des petites
améliorations qu'on doit faire c'est
vrai que l'année dernière on était
plutôt sur la fin et qui parce que là on
a rajouté la petite différence c'est
qu'on a ajouté quatre équipes
supplémentaires après c'est surtout au
niveau des petites choses comme
l'arbitrage on sait on s'est rendu
compte que c'était quelque chose de très
très important donc là on aura sur la
totalité du tournoi des arbitres on va
dire professionnel mais qui qui comme on
appelait ça évolue déjà au niveau -
league
[Musique]
l'idée c'est de réunir le maximum
effectivement de personnes qui sont
amoureux du football on sait tous que
pendant un certain nombre de temps on
n'a pas pu en profiter et donc la scéne
encore une occasion pour que le maximum
de personnes puisse puisse venir
l'entrée gratuite y aura de quoi se
restaurer le buvette sandwichs conclure
à des personnes beaucoup de pas mal de
bénévoles qui seront présents c'est pour
justement pour faire en sorte que les
gens passer une très belle après-midi
notamment cescom c'est sur deux jours un
samedi le samedi et dimanche
[Musique]